Oh
There are six main types of loneliness
one
Interpersonal loneliness, this is the result of losing a significant or intimate relationship?
To social loneliness, this is experienced when a person is on the fringes of a group excluded from a group, or is actively rejected
Three cultural loneliness a person who belongs to a different culture and feels like they don't fit or belong in the new culture
experiences culture loneliness
for
Intellectual loneliness. This is the result of feeling intellectually or educationally out of sync with peers family or social group
five
psychological loneliness, this is felt by someone who has undergone a traumatic situation that separated them from the people around them a
situation others can't fully understand
Six existential or cosmic loneliness, this is an isolating loneliness experienced by a person who is facing death
Hey guys, hope you enjoyed this video psych to go is planning to make some cool merch for you guys
And we're taking suggestions, so let us know if you have any ideas in the comments below
also
Be sure to check out our website and other social media as well as our new patreon account for more content and don't forget to
subscribe, thanks for watching